hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com so let me quickly introduce
myself i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong
on the option market actually and i've
just started to make
some youtube videos because guys i want
to pass the knowledge i want to show you
how actually procedures are working all
the different tools and techniques
that we used at least that those that
work for me
and i was i want to show you guys most
importantly how to use it yourself
so if you want to know about all the
stuff you guys in the right place
so today i want to make an update on rkt
rocket companies let's get into it
[Music]
so i do regular updates on rocket
companies guys because
it's one of the stock that i'm very
bullish on if
i change my view don't worry i'm gonna
let you know
i'm still very bullish and we saw
something very interesting two days ago
i mean i do this video i'm sorry i'm
always a bit late you know i do my
videos on the same day and i release it
daily so i try to do it two or three
times a week
because i still have my regular job but
whatever i i sometimes have some delay
whatever
so here i do it on the 30th of march
after the 30s of march close
and look what we had here so let me just
sum up the situation guys
two highs one trend line easy we break
it
so we have the strong breakout here we
retest it so here i was telling you guys
bye bye
bye you know i was very you know i mean
i don't give financial advice but
i would buy here a lot and unfortunately
i'm not allowed
to trade uh u.s stocks as part of my
contract
uh but whatever so here i would be a
very strong buyer
at this level then we go higher we come
back
again on this orange trend line that is
acting perfectly as support
we went to 22 so here it's like you know
beautiful levels to you know just
load more position and here
bam big volume we go higher we take 20
percent
and unfortunately it didn't hold
it got sold right away because there are
some sellers here let's take the short
interest
there are some sellers on this company
guys
and i don't think it's people who are
buying at 22 that are selling at 27 if
you know what i mean
so rkt
okay 20 of short interest so it's not
small but it's not very big so let's see
but this is data that was published
actually two weeks ago
the next one guys is on the fifth of
april i use this
schedule i can put it in the comments if
anyone asks
and you know for every u.s stocks when
the new data for the short interest is
actually going to be published
so for rocket companies we are at 20
let's see on the fifth of april if here
the shock interest increased and if some
hedge funds just sold
i mean i'm pretty sure they did so we're
gonna find out whatever
it is very it's still like a beautiful
level to buy and
you know the activity is kicking in guys
so when you have these volumes that are
you know
increasing on this day and it was still
even if the candle is red it was still a
bullish day guys we closed here
i mean it was a flat day okay but what
happened here was very interesting so
you can analyze this candle in different
ways but the analysis i have
is actually biased by my
bigger you know analysis that is very
bullish
so to me the scandal is just meaning
that you know buyers are just coming in
and they're going to push the price
higher quite soon
if i need to give you some targets in
terms of time horizon guys
it's not easy you know this can maybe
here you know it's kind of the worst
case scenario
and bam so it would be on the 8th of
april guys next week you know it's
coming soon
it's coming soon but careful guys once
again look where we're coming from we're
coming from
it's okay we're coming from 18. i mean
you know this is kind of the worst case
scenario is that
we just come back here so
so so using a stop loss here is not very
appropriate guys you know unfortunately
just
you know if you're buying the stuff just
don't buy too much maybe you know and so
you can buy more at this level but using
a stop loss here is not appropriate
i'm you know quite convinced that
something like this
is gonna happen soon uh in terms of
target
67 67 is a nice target guys if we go
there
it's gonna be the time to take some
profits because there's gonna be some
rejection for sure
we're not there yet guys we have time
but yeah that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore as you guys